that party let's his father and father
to the left the party is losing the
basic willpower needed to perpetuate
civilized living garbage is piling up in
Democrat cities from coast to coast as
municipal government no longer cares
enough to keep their cities clean so
instead third parties are stepping up
Scott Ressler is a conservative activist
who's organized major cleanups in
several cities most recently his group
of volunteers removed trash in Chicago
and in Austin Texas and the Pressler
joins us now Scott you started this
after someone quite incredibly in the
21st century developed a flesh-eating
disease he caught a flesh-eating disease
just from walking through the streets of
Los Angeles that's right yeah when we
went into Los Angeles I was adamant that
every single volunteer wear a hazmat
suit so when we picked up 50 tons of
trash we had booties gloves hazmat suits
on to pick up trash in LA that's that's
amazing that it's actually not safe to
walk around without a hazmat suit these
these are the guys by the way who keep
telling us that they're saving the
planet but can't actually just save the
environment can't actually keep their
own streets clean well I think the
difference is you know I am a
conservative activist I'm a
bleeding-heart conservative that instead
of pointing my finger at people and
saying how dare you I dare to go out
with volunteers and pick up trash now
let me just ask you about the politics
of that because there's a lot of thought
all these cities have been Democrat run
for decades and they're filthy if if you
knew California cities half a century
ago you would think that they'd been
nuked or they'd been bombed or something
terrible terrible catastrophe had
befallen them and the politics of it
would would seem to suggest that you
just say okay let's let's leave it to
these Democrats to run their cities into
the ground and then people will get the
message why do you prefer to actually
act and clean up these dumps
well my statement by
to Democrat runs cities is overtly
political I don't have to go in as a
Republican or a trump supporter simply
the fact that I is a Virginian had to go
into Baltimore Los Angeles Chicago
Austin I'm making a political statement
but I'm not pointing the finger
my motto is stop talking start doing so
I'm leading with love and I'm leading by
example being an environmental steward
and showing that Republicans do care
about the environment all we want is to
make America a cleaner greener place
what was Chicago like because to most
non Chicagoans that's a place of great
danger you had hundreds of volunteers
out with you on the streets of Chicago
that's right in the most dangerous city
and I say that with quotations we had
250 volunteers all from Twitter Facebook
Instagram that were on 63rd Street and I
want to give a shout out to pastor Corey
Brooks who opened Project Hood in his
doors to us in Chicago and in in Austin
you also got some praise from the
governor you you you found hundreds and
hundreds of needles that presumably
could just be lying around all terrible
things could could happen there the
governor actually thanked you for what
you did he did yeah governor Greg Abbott
has done a great job actually going into
the city of Austin and helping to clean
up and the spot that we cleaned up under
an overpass and under I 83 a homeless
camp the governor actually sent a
cleanup crew to go in there so governor
Abbott is doing a wonderful job even
though the mayor of Austin isn't doing
his work
what's the reason that the the City of
Austin the city of Chicago the the city
of San Francisco what's the reason that
they actually can't I mean that's a
creep garbage collection
that's as basic a municipal function a
function of government as anything
what's the reason they can't do it you
know it's it's all politics mark when we
applied for dumpsters for the city of
Baltimore the first time we were denied
permits denied and that doesn't tell me
anything else except for a
politically motivated to stop a
conservative from coming in to pick up
trash and so we did it anyway stop
talking start doing hey good good good
for you you don't need permits it's a
basic civilizational function to to be
able to keep your streets clean thanks a
lot for that Scott